ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้ที่ทำนักเรียนโอเค
สวัสดีครับสวัสดีครับเพื่อนแกอ้าวันนี้
เรากลับมาเจอกันอีกแล้วกลับมาเจอพี่
อาร์ตี้แล้วก็เจอกับน้องเรียมนะครับโอเค
เรามาเจอกันแล้วอ้าเรามาเจอกันวันนี้วัน
นี้วันที่เท่าไหร่ครับที่เรามาเจอกันวัน
นี้วันที่ 16 ค่ะหน้าวันนี้วันที่ 16 นะ
ครับเดี๋ยวเบียร์ตี้แจกปฏิทินมาก่อน
ปฏิทินจงมาโอเคปฏิทินมาแล้ววันนี้วันที่
16 นะครับที่ 16  28 โอเควันที่ 16 อยู่
ตรงไหนครับวันที่สดเป็นวันอะไรเอ่ยวันที่
16 วันอะไรครับเสาร์ค่ะหาใช้ฝั่ง theatre
ที่ 6 วันเสาร์นี้มีวันที่ถูกวันเสาร์
แล้วเดือนอะไรครับเดือนนี้แต่เดือนตุลาคม
เดือนนี้เดือน
ตุลาคมค.เดือนตุลาคมนะครับปีคริสตศักราช
ปีคริสตศักราช
2021  21  5 ใช่แล้วแล้วปีพุทธศักราชจีบ
ของศักราช
2564  5  64 ใช่แล้วครับเดี๋ยวเควันนี้
วันที่
วันเสาร์ที่ 16 ตุลาคม 2012  21 นะครับ
อ่าโอเคโอเคแล้วตอนนี้ตอนนี้ครับตอนนี้
ตอนนี้คือเวลาเวลาเท่าไหร่ครับหาเวลาได้
10:10 นนค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้
งงอ่ะ
10:00 นอ่ะแล้วก็สิบนาทีอ่ะฮะโอเค
เนี่ยเยี่ยมเลย 10:10 นนะครับอ่าหัวหน้า
วันนี้วันนี้วันนี้น้องเรียมเตรียมอะไรมา
เตรียมอะไรมันเล่าให้พี่อาร์ตี้ฟังเตรียม
อะไรมันเล่าให้นักเรียนฟังกันอ้ะนักเรียน
ร้อนค่ะเบียร์สิรอรอครับวันนี้ร้อน 5 วัน
นี้ร้อนบ้านพี่อาร์ตี้ก็ร้อนเหมือนกันคืน
นี้ก็กำลังร้องในเขาเสี่ยมอยู่ที่บ้านรู้
สึกร้อนหออยู่ที่บ้านร้อนใช่ไหมหาบ้าน
เพื่อตี้ก็ร้อนเหมือนกันแต่วันเฮียตีอยู่
ที่บ้านเยอะตี้เปิดแอร์เปิด 5 ๆโอเคตีกู
ไม่ร้อนแต่ถ้าออกเป็นนอกบ้านออกไปข้างนอก
บ้านข้างนอกบ้านก็จะร้อนร้อนช่ายเพียบนี่
ค่ะเพื่อที่เปิดแอร์ที่บ้าน
เปิดแอร์ที่บ้านหาใช่ครับเย็นโอ๊ยตายๆชาย
ได้ค่ะเปิดแอพ
หาแต่ว่าพี่อาร์ตี้ก็จะจ่ายเงินจะต้อง
จ่ายเงินค่าค่าไฟค่าไฟฟ้าแอร์เนี่ยที่
เปิดอะไรต้องจ่ายเงินด้วยจ่ายเงินค่าไฟ
ฟ้า
ๆครับเยอะมาก
ก็เปิดแค่เปิดเฉพาะตอนที่ร้อนมากๆตอนที่
ร้อนนิดเดียวร้อนนิดเดียวก็ไม่ต้องเปิด
ไม่ต้องเปิดใช่ใช่ครับทนร้อนฮ่าๆร้อนมาก
เพจนี้ค่อยเปิดเปิดหน้าต่างตอนที่ร้อนนิด
เดียวตอนที่ร้อนนิดเดียวก็เปิดหน้าต่าง
เปิดหน้าต่าง
เปิดหน้าต่างเปิด
อ่านเวลาเปิดหน้าต่างก็จะมี
ลมก็จะพัดเข้ามาใต้ใช้ครับ
ว่าเราก็จะเย็นสบายๆแล้วอ่ะอ่ะแล้วน้อง
เรียมน้องเรียนร้อนนักเรียนทำยังไงวันนี้
วันนี้น้องเรียนจะทำยังไงเนี่ยตอนนี้ต้อง
เรียนเมียร้อนหรือใช่ไหม
เวลาเรียนร้อนเดี๋ยวจะออกไปข้างนอกบ้านไป
ข้างนอกห้องออกไปข้างนอกบ้านก็ยิ่งร้อน
ใหญ่ออกไปข้างนอกก็ยิ่งร้อน
เดี๋ยวออกไปห้างสิคะอ๋อ
ไปเกมสบายหมอไปห้างไปห่างๆคืออะไรครับ
ห้างห้างสรรพสินค้าที่เราไปซื้อของ
อ๋ออ๋อห้างสรรพสินค้าที่เราขับรถ
ขับรถมอเตอร์ไซค์ขับมอเตอร์ไซค์ไปไปให้
ใช่ไหมอ๋อใครอย่า
ให้ขาดใช่ไหมครับขอโอเคเออใส่ออกไปห้าง
เพราะขับมอเตอร์ไซค์ไปให้เรียงก็จะขับ
มอเตอร์ไซค์ไปที่ห้างขอโอเคว้าวเวลาร้อน
ร้อนก็ไม่อยู่บ้านไม่อยู่บ้านขับ
มอเตอร์ไซค์ไปไหนอ๋อ
โอเคขับมอเตอร์ไซค์ไปที่ห้างไปที่ห้าง
แล้วไปทำอะไรอีกครับเราจะก็จะเดินเข้าไป
อ๋ออ๋อเดินซึ่งไม่อ๋อนี่ในห้างที่ห้างก็
จะมีร้านค้าเยอะแยะเลยใช่ไหมใช่แล้วค่ะมี
ร้านค้าในห้างอ่ะแล้วอ่าน้องเรียมขับ
มอเตอร์ไซค์มาใช่ไหมเมื่อกี้ขับ
มอเตอร์ไซค์มาเราก็ต้องเข้ามาที่ห้างก่อน
นะตอนเข้ามาตี 5 ก็เพราะเธอคืออะไรครับ
เนี่ยเดินเข้าไปก็จะเจอประตู
ประตูเลื่อนอ๋ออ๋อนี่คือประตูเลื่อนประตู
จะเลื่อน 5 พระพุทะโนมัติอ๋อประตูเลื่อน
อัตโนมัติเลยว้าวเราไม่ต้องเอามือไปจับ
ไม่ต้องง้อประตูมันก็จะเลือกเองใช่ไหมใช่
ค่ะเราเดินเข้าไป
ใกล้ๆประตูแล้วประตูก็จะเลื่อน
อ๋ออ๋อเราก็ค่ะเดินเข้าไปได้แล้วประตูมัน
ปิดเองๆประตูเลื่อนอัตโนมัติขอเรียกว่า
ประตูอัตโนมัติเราไม่ต้องเปิดแล้วไม่ต้อง
ทำอะไรเลยเราแค่ไปยืนหน้าประตูแล้วประตู
ก็เปิดแล้วเราก็เดินเข้าไปเออ
ว้าวเป็นดูอ่ะจังเลยหน้าไม่ต้องเปิดประตู
ไม่ก็ปิดประตูโอเคอ่ะประตู
อัตโนมัติให้ค่ะช่วงนี้โควิชนะคะพี่
อาร์ตี้ขอช่วงนี้กันโควิชแล้วเราต้องทำ
ยังไงครับเราก็จะไม่เอามือปิดจัดอะไรหรือ
ว่าเวลาที่เราจะเดินเข้าห้างเขาก็ต้องใส่
แมสขอทำไมหน้ากากอนามัยอันนี้หานี้คือแม้
ที่เป็นเพื่อป้องกันป้องกันเชื้อโควิกใช่
ไหมให้ใส่หน้ากากอ่านตอนที่พี่ออกไปนอก
บ้านเฮียตีก็ใส่หน้ากากเหมือนกัน
หน้ากากอนามัย
ๆใส่หน้ากากอนามัยทุกคนเวลาที่ออกนอกบ้าน
ต้องใส่หน้ากากนะครับ 5 อนามัยใจเลยให้
ครับน่าโอเคใส่หน้ากากอนามัยนะครับถ้าเรา
พอไปใส่หน้าอานามัยเดินเข้าประตูไปแล้วนะ
ครับยังต้องทำยังไงอีกครับมีอะไรอีกไหม
ต้องหวัดคุณหภูมิค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้วัด
อุณหภูมิคุณภูมิที่ตัวเราใช่ไหมต้องวัด
อ๋อก็มีอะเคยเห็นใช่เป็นเครื่องวัด
อุณหภูมิ
อันนี้เป็นเครื่องวัดอุณหภูมิมายิงที่ยิง
นี้ตรงหน้าผากจะไม่ตรงนี้เรียกว่าหน้าผาก
5 มาวัดควรภูมิที่นะผ่าขอ
หรือว่าบางอันก็ใช้มือนะคะใช้มืออ๋ออ๋อ
มายที่มือใช่ไหมวัดที่มือให้วัดที่มือซิ
แต่ว่าเครื่องนี้เครื่องนี้จะยิงที่หน้า
ผากอ๋อโอเคเครื่องนี้ยิงที่หน้าผากหน้ามี
ใช่ค่ะถ้าเกิดขึ้นตรงนี้ใช่ไหมเนี่ยใช่
เขาวอลเล่ขึ้นมีตัวเลขเป็นอุณหภูมิของตัว
เราใช่ไหมอ้าวอ้ากี่องศา
ใช่ค่ะกี่องศาถ้าเกิด
37  37 องศาขึ้นไป
จะเข้าห้างไม่ได้ก็ทำมากกว่ามากกว่า 37
องศา
เช้าไม่ได้อ๋อ
อ้าวทำไมล่ะครับทำไมมากกว่า 37 องศาเข้า
ไม่ได้แล้วครับเขาจะคิดว่าเราไม่สบายหมอ
ถ้าเราไม่สบายตัวเราก็จะร้อนใช่ไหมตัวก็
โทรหรอกอุณหภูมิก็จะสูง 37  5  37.5
38 แสดงว่าไม่สบายอะไรสบายๆอาจจะเป็นโค
วิชก็ได้หรืออาจจะไม่อย่าลืมเป็นหน้าแต่
ที่ห้างเก่าก็ไม่ให้เข้าไม่เข้าไปก่อน
กลับบ้านไปก่อนไม่ให้เข้าเจ๊ขอแล้วน้อง
เรียนอุณหภูมิเท่าไหร่ครับ
เรียนไปถึง 5 เมตรคูณเท่าไหร่อุณหภูมิ
36 ขอขอบ
16.8
แปลโอเคยังไม่ถึงยังไม่
37 นะยังไม่ถึง 37 เขตเข้าได้โอเคได้ฮ๋า
ๆๆ
แล้วที่ 5 เขาก็จะให้เราล้างมืออ๋ออ๋อ
ล้างมือด้วยใช่ไหมครับ 5 นี้ล้างมือด้วย
อะไรครับทั้งมือถืออะไรเจลแอลกอฮอล์
อ๋ออ๋อมีอ่ะก็รออยู่ในนี้ใช่ไหมแล้วก็คอ
เดี๋ยวนี้เป็นครับ
อย่างนี้เขาก็พอใช่ไหมครับแล้วก็บีบลงมา
ที่มือแล้วก็ล้างมึงเอามือมาถูกกันแบบนี้
เราก็จะกดกดออกลงมาจากด้านบนตรงนี้กดลงมา
r เอาถุงมือ
ในมืออ้าแล้วก็ถูกมือ
ขอว้าวเพื่อทำไมต้องล้างมืออ่ะครับให้มัน
สะอาดขอมือจะได้สะอาดแล้วก็จะแบบทีเรีย
ฆ่าเชื้อโร่
ถ้าเดินไป
ร้านกาแฟ
ไอ้แล้วนี่ครับเจอแล้วร้านกาแฟอยู่นี่
หน้าร้านกาแฟอยู่นี่เอง
ทำไมถึงหาร้านกาแฟครับ
เรียงหาที่นั่งทำงานอ๋ออยู่ที่บ้านอยู่
ที่บ้านร้อนมานั่งทำงานมานั่งทำงานที่
ร้าน
ฮ่อโอเคโอเคดีครับอ่ะเตรียมก็จะเดินเข้า
ไปในร้านกาแฟ
ขับเดินเข้าไปในร้านกาแฟครับแล้วก็มองหา
5 มองหามองหาอะไรครับมองหาโต๊ะ
อ๋ออ๋อมองหาโต๊ะ
โต๊ะที่จะนั่งทำงานใช่ไหมครับไม่ค่ะผมขอ
นอน
ในร้านกาแฟ
ว้าวให้ค่ะถ้านั่งดื่มกาแฟไปด้วย
ทำงานไปด้วยข้อแล้วก็เย็นสบายด้วยเปลี่ยน
สบายไม่ต้องจ่ายไม่ต้องจ่ายค่าไฟเองไม่
ต้องจ่ายค่าไปอ่ะฮ่าๆ
เพราะว่าเรียงจะเอากระเป๋าคอมพิวเตอร์
เอากระเป๋าใส่คอมพิวเตอร์ไป
ไปด้วย
เฮ้ยต้องหาโต๊ะ
หาโต๊ะที่มี 5 อ๊อดไปขอ
หาตอนที่มีปลั๊กไฟด้วยอ๋อจะได้จะได้เสียบ
ปลั๊กคอมพิวเตอร์ได้ใช่ไหมค่ะคะเดี๋ยว
ขอเสียบชาร์จ 5 เสร็จพักคอมพิวเตอร์เพื่อ
ที่จะทำงานว้าวเพลง 5 รักชัดโทรศัพท์
ทำงานด้วยทำงานด้วยดูโทรศัพท์ด้วยคุยนะ
ครับด้วยโอเคอ่าแล้วก็กินกาแฟไปด้วย
อาหารโต๊ะที่มี
รักไฟมีปลั๊กไฟด้วยอ๋อเพื่อที่จะได้เสียบ
ขับจะได้เสียบ
รักเราโอเคอาทำงานอ้าวแล้วก็ทำงานได้เห็น
ต้องสั่งสั่งเครื่องดื่มก่อนนะคะขออ่า
ต้องสั่ง
สั่ง
สั่งกาแฟอ๋อ
แต่บางครั้งก็ได้
กาแฟ
สั่งกาแฟก็ได้กูว่ากาแฟร้อน
กาแฟว่าได้แต่ว่าเรียมชอบเตรียมชอบชอบ
อะไรครับ
กูเอาช็อกโกโห้ 5 เขาสัตว์มุกก็มา
โกโก้เย็นค่ะ
สั่งโกโก้ก็คือการซื้อซื้อโกโก้ใช่ไหม
ครับซื้ออาหารเราเรียกว่าสั่งหน้าเหมือน
กัน 5 ซื้อเท่ากับสั่งเท่ห์สั่งโกโก้ร้อน
สั่งโกโก้ร้อน
ฉันโกโก้ร้อนอาหาร
โอเคอ่ะปกติกินปี่แก้วครับแต่ตอนนี้ทำแนว
เดียวค่ะโกโก้ไปด้วยอ้ากินแก้วเดียวใช่
ไหมอ๋อโอเคแก้วเดียวขอ
เสียบปลั๊กเสียบป่ะ
ทำงานอ่ะใช้ไฟของเขาใช้ไฟที่ร้านกาแฟใช่
ไหมอ่าไลค์แชร์ใช้แอร์เย็นๆสบายที่ร้าน
กาแฟก็
ใช้โต๊ะของเขาทำงานที่ร้านกาแฟ
โอเค
ไปหยัดจังเลยครับให้แอร์ใช้ไฟใช้ต๊อบก็
ใช้หลายอย่างเลยให้ฮักไฟด้วย
อาหารอีกครับ
แล้วยังไงต่อครับจะนานอยู่นะมาทำงานนาน
ไหมครับทำงานก็
30 นาทีนะคะข้อสามสิบนาที
ครับก็จะรู้สึกหิวข้าว
เพิ่งทำงาน 30 นาทีหิวข้าวแล้วหรอหิวข้าว
เร็วจัง
อยากกินข้าวอ๋อหิวแล้วอ่ะอ่ะหิวแล้วครับ
เพราะหิวแล้วทำยังไงครับทีนี้ลายริมหิว
ข้าวแต่ว่าตอนนี้อยู่ในร้านกาแฟใช่ไหมใน
ร้านกาแฟมีข้าวไหมที่ร้านกาแฟไม่มีข้าว
ขายกาแฟขายโกโก้ไม่ได้ขายข้าวมอบ kane
แล้วทำยังไงครับนิที่ต้องทำ
เดินออกจากร้านกาแฟอ๋ออ๋อเด้อเอ่อออกจาก
ร้านกาแฟครับแล้วก็หมอนหาหน้าไปหาหาอะไร
ครับที่นี้ร้านอาหาร
ร้านอาหารอ่ะที่มีข้าวขายใช่ไหม
อ้าวอ๋ออ่อนี้ครับร้านอาหารใช่ไหมที่น้อง
เรียมเตรียมมา 5 ไปไปอาหาร 5 ไปกินข้าว
ที่ร้านอาหารอ๋อโอเคเวลาที่น้องเรียมไป
ที่ร้านอาหารน้องเรียม
สั่งอะไรครับ
หรืออะไรมากินครับ
เรียงซื้อ
สลัดขอซื้อสลัดหน้าน้องเรียมชอบกินสลัด
ล่ะครับใช่ค่ะเรียกชอบสลัด 5 ทำไมทำไมถึง
ชอบกินสลัดครับ
เรียบชอบกินขอ
ขออ่อในสลัดจะมีผักใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะจะมีผับจะ
มีทั้งขับสลัด
หน้าผักสลัดใช่ผักสลัดมีแค่หลอด
อ๋อมีโทษกินข้าวโพดด้วยว้าว
เหมือนเค้าพูดไม่
เหมือนมะม่วงโอเคเหมือนเขาก็
โอเคโอเค
ขอมีข้าวโพดอยู่ในสลัดด้วยหน้าเป็นข้าว
โพดแล้วอ่ะทีนี้เป็นข้าวโพดแล้วครับโทษ
หมอมีพาดชอบอยู่
มีแครอทแล้วก็มีข้าวโพดออกก็เลยชอบให้คะ
มาที่กินข้าว
พี่ข้าวพี่อาร์ตี้กาจะชอบสั่งข้าวมากกว่า
5 คนไทยคนไทยนิยมกินข้าวใช่ครับกินข้าว
หรือหาหรือกินหาก๋วยเตี๋ยวจ้าใช่ 5 นัก
เรียนนักเรียนเคยกินก๋วยเตี๋ยวไหมครับ
เป็นเตียงนะเดี๋ยวใช่ก๋วยเตี๋ยวที่ใช้
ตะเกียบที่เกี่ยวที่มีชามแล้วก็มีตะเกียบ
5 มีตะเกียบถูกต้องก็มี
อ้ามีช้อนด้วยเราใช้ช้อนตักน้ำซุปกินๆๆ
เดี๋ยวน้าไม่ชอบกินสลาดกินสลัดไม่อิ่มๆ
อีกเพียบรีบ
กินสลัดข้าว
ไปเขาต้องสั่งก๋วยเตี๋ยวหรือไม่
หรือถ้าไม่สั่งก๋วยเตี๋ยวก็สั่งข้าวสั่ง
ข้าว
ขับเรื่อยฮะแล้วกินข้าวเสร็จแล้วเรียงก็
จะไปร้านหนังสือ
ออกไปร้านหนังสือต่ออีกได้ทำงานเสร็จแล้ว
กินข้าวเสร็จแล้วนะครับอ่าอ่ะเดี๋ยวไป
เดินที่ร้านหนังสือ
เหงายังเรียบต้องร้านหนังสือล่ะครับใช่
ค่ะยี่ห้อไปคืนนานมากๆโอ้วไปทำอะไรครับใน
ร้านหนังสือนานๆไปทำอะไรนานาด้วยสี
ไปดูหนังสือแล้วก็ไปอ่าน
อ่านหนอไปหาหนังสือที่ร้านหนังสือ
เรียนชอบเรียนก็จะซื้อของโทรหาโอเคดีจริง
จังเสียงขู่นานมากๆประมาณโห 4 ชั่วโมง
หือ 4 ชั่วโมง
นานงาน
น้องเรียมไม่ได้นอนหลับใช่ไหมไม่ได้ไปนอน
4 ชั่วโมง
นานนานมะฮะเอมชอบชอบแบบมีหนังสือหนังสือ
หนังสือหนังสือรอบ
เราก็ชอบเหลือเยอะๆ
หรือหมอก็เลยไปอยู่ที่ร้านหนังสือนานเลย
เห้ยก็ขับมอเตอร์ไซค์กลับมาที่บ้านอ๋อก็
อ่าทำงานเสร็จแล้วกินข้าวเสร็จแล้ว
นะครับอ่ะอ่ะอ่านหนังสือ 4 ชั่วโมงจอีก
เเล้วฮ่าๆก็กลับบ้านใช่ไหมครับหอมค่ะ
เปลือกบ้านบ้านน้อเจ๊
หายดีเลยครับนี่ก็คือวันหยุดวันนี้ของนัก
เรียนเพราะว่าวันนี้เป็นวันเสาร์ใช่ไหม
ถ้าวันเสาร์ก็หมดไปแล้วนะครับของเราที่
เราร้อนก็ออก
อ๋อโอเคค่ะดีครับถ้างั้นเดี๋ยวคราวหน้า
คราวหน้าล็อคกลับมาคุยกันใหม่นะครับว่า
น้องเรียมกับเฮียตี้จะผ่านนักเรียนไปที่
ไหนกันไปทำอะไรกันข่าวหน้านะครับอ่ะงั้น
เดี๋ยววันนี้คิดหน้าวันนี้ต้องไปก่อนนะคะ
สวัสดีนะคะพี่อาร์ตี้ดีครับน้องเรียมจะ
สวัสดีครับนักเรียน
by ออกไปข้างนึง
ไปปะครับมอเตอร์ไซค์